you guys like gravy no I love it that
grape is cool great gravy too like yummy
gravy yeah like that's got that like
really flavorful sort of vibe to it I
like to cook I don't know
um I started doing covert like just
burning [__] yeah like just because you
know we couldn't go to restaurants it
was all crazy and stuff like that so one
of my favorite things that I got out of
covet was learning how to cook like go
on a Food Network grab all those
ingredients and try to make some [__] it
was actually fun what'd you make ah wow
one of my favorite things that I made
um I made a Caribbean
um salmon with mangoes and um Peppers so
you and then you have to use Tamarind
Tamarind yeah yeah man yeah man like it
was but it was so yummy with Bland rice
you started cooking too in the pandemic
yeah potato right potatoes you got it
you called yourself a potato cake during
the Van Damme oh the potato King yeah
yeah I made baked potatoes you learned
how to make baked potatoes you learn how
to make
yeah that's like saying I learned how to
boil water
you know I wrap it up
put in the [__] oven right right I
looked through the window the whole time
because I have a light thing because
I lit up the stove okay right I think
it's ready put some butter in it
one of the other things I don't know how
we get on the food but another thing
that I learned that I really really like
is the um uh uh
uh the what is it it Cooks fast it's
gonna start not disturbing yeah it's the
air fryer air fryer yeah the thing is
her body bro I I have I love hair the
air fryer can do so much [__] you it's
crazy like you can just do stuff quick
you can um it gives it a certain kind of
crispness yeah like dog meat I love
Dogma oh you do no
it Cooks so fast
dude it's so good
we're gonna get the animal people yeah
Bobby let me holla
I'm kidding I've never open up your
airplane equivalent to like um child CPS
for dogs because they might take our
dogs away if you keep talking about
eating this is a joke
you've heard of that stereotype though
right yes yeah you don't have family
members that did that because I do that
still dude yeah you know in Korea my dad
ate it yeah so back in the day yeah so
it's real it's all the way real yeah
it's all the way but back in the day in
the when during the Korean War there
wasn't a lot of like cows hanging out
right you gotta eat what you got to eat
what is the Asian Korean cow sound like
[Laughter]
or what's a Korean chicken sound like
oh [__] yeah yeah but what give me a
chicken sound look oh
that's the Philippines that's the
Filipino chicken we've gone through this
we'll do it oh yeah all right you know
what dude this is sound Asian as it is
yeah yeah you're right they don't have
an accent
[Laughter]
it was a cheaper meat I guess yeah but
like it's available it was available but
now I guess there still is a industry in
Korea but I don't know much I don't know
anyone that's eaten it can I tell you a
funny story really good yeah so uh first
time I go to
what was that I was in Japan yeah I was
in Japan right and
um very high-end my wife and I were
traveling from we had went to Bali and
we'd come across Bobby stopped and he
was like yeah we're going to do a couple
stops back so we stopped and we go to
this real fly ass like five star
um Japanese restaurant whatever and I
was like you know I'm a foodie so I'm
like I'm always trying some new [__] and
[__] I'm like yeah I'm gonna get the
[__] duck oh duck I'm gonna get
the duck yeah and they said you deserved
and they said the duck comes with this
incredible sauce and it's gonna be live
it's gonna be dope I'm gonna say okay
baby I'm getting the duck so I'm sitting
there right
they brought the duck out and the duck
was looking at me like this they brought
to you live no no not live today
but I thought I thought it was going to
be all cut up like like you know like
this and this but the duck with the beak
and everything but it was it was
eyeballs bro yeah
I was like yo like the funny part
because I'm thinking you know in America
we used to like just duck and you get
the little drizzle sauce yeah I'm
thinking it's gonna come like that no it
was the duck it was cooked beautifully
but it was right in front of you it's
like oh [__] and I can still see him go
man you pick me
thanks a lot bro thanks man yeah I just
got here I'm dead did you put little
sunglasses on yeah
that's sort of why I do respect Asians
though because in the Philippines we
serve the pig a whole that's what I'm
saying oh [__] I think that it's almost
like we cannot deny the reality of our
food
same because I'm thinking
it up like when I saw that I'm thinking
of the park
or Donald Duck yeah
I think that's what we deserve like a
little bit of sadness when we enjoy the
flavor because like but it was so good I
just couldn't look at him
I said please please can you take them
in the back
of me back and just just cut it up the
way I could so I can't look at it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wow I remember
one time
um I go out with D.L Hughley like this
one oh my God the nicest guy in the
world greatest guy and he always knows
great restaurants right so
he takes us to some crazy upscale [__]
and we ordered like a fish that was like
a [__]